it's the national pastime in a nation
that feels stuck in the past on this
field of abandoned kids dream about a
future that's often centered on that
country's most famous team
industrialists the New York Yankees of
Cuba ticket prices may be lower here
than at Yankee Stadium but the fans can
compete when it comes to passion and
some players can compete when it comes
to talent they want to show how good
they are and play baseball or a higher
level that's the first reason I think
the other reasons our financial industry
Ellis manager Lazaro Vargas understands
all too well why many players here
including his 15 year old son Antonio
might want to play in the US but
government attempts to keep these
players in Cuba have created an
underground industry for human smuggling
and Major League Baseball's own rules
have provided the financial incentives
that fund it it's nothing more than
still in talent from Cuban bate and I
believe that we are spending tons of
money in these young players and then
the traffickers are taking them to the
United States to play baseball
but the precise details of this perilous
passage to America often remain shrouded
in secrecy the Cuban baseball players
don't talk the smugglers obviously
aren't talking the agents who are
negotiating their contracts aren't
talking pull mine off is a Florida
Attorney who's represented lianas
Martine a Cuban center fielder who to
boost his signing value with the Texas
Rangers travel to the US via Mexico
that's because Cuban nationals to
qualify as international free agents
that can sign these huge contracts must
first establish residency in a third
country these are the golden geese these
are the guys who are going to bring them
significant amounts of money just
because you get out of Cuba doesn't
guarantee that you will ever a make your
way into America and B make your way
into a major league baseball team but
high-profile Cuban signings like these
players who do make it to a major league
team are often on the hook to pay off
the smugglers that help them get there
they are a small team paid his smugglers
a million three hundred and fifty
thousand dollars it's a big number it's
a lot of money
and when it comes to money teams like
industrialists can hardly compete their
best young player is Lord s jr. a 21
year old second baseman whom experts
told us could be worth as much as 80 or
90 million dollars if he ever signed as
a free agent to a major league team his
current base salary is less than $38 a
month when one of your friends leaves to
go and play in America what do you think
about that if someone is encouraged to
play in the best league and it's not
secret that it's the u.s. you always
encourage a friend because ultimately
they are a friend and you wish them the
best in a state-controlled sport both
the players who leave and the smugglers
who assist them are equally considered
enemies of the revolution and even as
the two countries slowly inch closer a
vast gulf remains between a
multi-billion dollar business and this
island international sport